ah
Walter
welcome wastelanders to your home of
everything modifying over-the-top and
with a strange green glow to it
I'm your host Dave Drew and I'm here to
tell you all about this week's mod the
Firelands 2.0 standalone a brighter and
more badass version of fallouts default
alien blaster can be yours but you're
gonna have to work for it if you want to
earn this weapon and you know you don't
want to spawn it through console
commands then you'll have to dine your
power armor pop some radix and wade into
the glowing sea you can find hints of
its location on some loading screens but
you'll need to find a parking garage in
the middle of the irradiated wastelands
and then dispatch the powerful alien
commander to become the proud new owner
of this awesome sci-fi firestorm it's
nice to have a weapon mod that requires
a little bit of work to obtain weapons
and armor that are placed in crates and
sanctuary are fine but taking the extra
times at a short adventure to gain the
weapon gives them out a bit more flavor
which I can really appreciate on the
surface the weapon appears to be a
reskin of the alien blaster with a deep
phred replacing the bright blue but the
mod actually combines other pieces of
weapons such as the plasma rifle and
flamer weapons to create something brand
new the mod author lists one of the
features as crazy damage so there is a
lower damage variant if you want to keep
the challenge alive the weapon is fully
moddable and allows you to turn this
bright red Belcher of death into a wide
variety of exciting new toys long-range
sniper rifles to zap your foes to ash
from afar super rapid shotguns to chew
through your enemies at terrifying speed
or a handheld flamethrower to create
some deep-fried super mutant on the go
some ways Landers aren't the biggest
fans of the alien element of the Fallout
series although they've been quite minor
if you loved mothership Zita and enjoy
the alien weapons in the Fallout series
then you'll love this weapon if it's
well into the Fallout universe as long
as you don't mind the extra-terrestrial
element of the storyline and combining
sci-fi laser weapons with reducing
enemies to ash create some satisfying
gunplay if you try this mod or just
think the idea is cool then I'd love to
hear your opinions so make sure you
leave them in the comment section below
or tweet them using the hashtag GS
fallout even better if you've got a mod
to show us yourself then share that too
and maybe you'll see it next week when
we'll be covering another awesome
fallout 4 mod but until then thanks so
much for watching and stay safe out
there wasteland err